[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour
une nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction une édition largement
consacrée en ce 30 mars au résultat des
élections départementales l'union de la
droite et du centre qui réalise dans les
yvelines dans les yvelines un grand
chelem 21 cantons 42 sièges acquis et
pierre bédier devrait logiquement
retrouver son poste de président dès
jeudi la semaine de la presse 26e
édition et au collège maurice ravel à
montfort l'amaury les élèves et les
enseignants ont échangé autour de
l'actualité récente et puis en sport
retour sur la coupe de france de bmx
2015 qui vient de se tenir au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
meilleurs de la discipline qui se sont
affrontés ce week-end durant 48 heures
l'ump et ses alliés du centre udc modem
ont donc réussir leur pari ils ont fait
le grand chelem dans le département et
recueille plus de 68% des suffrages avec
deux cent cinquante trois mille voix à
la droite remporte 21 cantons sur 21
dans les yvelines
la gauche qui comptait neuf conseillers
généraux avant les élections ne sera
plus représenté dans ce nouveau conseil
départemental les forces de gauche qui
totalise 19,71 % des suffrages le front
national qui avait pourtant réussi à se
maintenir dans huit cantons pour ce
deuxième tour ne décroche n'ont plus
aucun siège le parti de marine le pen
obtient après 2 44 mille voix en termes
de participation les yvelinois au moins
voté pour ce second tour seulement 42,50
2% contre 45,34 pour son premier tour
des électeurs beaucoup moins mobilisés
qu'au plan national où près de 50 %
d'entre elles s'étaient déplacés aux
urnes on écoute qu'est remédier le
président sortant du conseil
départemental
l'objectif étape terre crois que c'est
une belle victoire
un beau sujet de satisfaction parce que
cet objectif est atteint d'abord parce
qu'on avait des bons candidats avec des
candidats issus des dernières élections
municipales qui ont fait des scores
remarquables dans leur village je pense
à karl olive à poissy 78 % dans
dans son canton c'est aussi le résultat
d'un travail de projets de bon projet
qui a été présenté aux yvelinois un
bilan qui était reconnu et puis une
stratégie qui a été celle de l'union de
la droite du centre avec lui des i avec
le modem et même en allant plus loin
avec des divers droite et des divers
gauche et que pensez vous de ce grand
chelem c'est notre question du jour au
micro d' elodie moine c'est pas négatif
au contraire ça sans cesse que ce qu'on
souhaitait et l'air concentré par
rapport à ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant
ça m'étonne qu'ils aient pas plus
extrême droite par contre mais ça
m'étonne pas du tout pour la droite ce
qui risque de devoir d'avoir une
certaine unanimité alors que c'est bien
d'avoir des avis inverse pour pouvoir
créer justement enfin puis surtout se
remettre en question ce tournant ça
prouve aussi que du coût de la politique
de la gauche elle déplaît à beaucoup de
français et que du coup la droite
remonte
c'était inéluctable compte tenu de la
situation économique compte tenu de du
chômage etc
ramé
le la marche à suivre ensuite ne sera
pas empreintes de démocratie et nous
allons regarder à présent dans le détail
les résultats sur différents cantons
autour de saint quentin en yvelines en
commençant par montigny le bretonneux où
le président de l'agglomération se
présentait sous l'étiquette de l'union
de la droite avec laurence rochus face
au sortant le socialiste françois de
ligne et appuyer avec par sandrine grand
gaube responsable départemental du ps le
reportage de mélanie poquet monte au
logis levon ce rejet de celui de 332
voix soit 53,1
les partisans de l'union de la droite
savourent leur victoire
michel laugier le maire de la commune et
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et laurence
trochut viennent d'être élus conseillers
départementaux avec 53 points 48% des
voix sur dix morts de joie déjà parce
que lorsqu'on gagne un canton dans
lequel on est challenger mais ça fait
plaisir en plus le gagner d'une si belle
façon je crois j'ai de grandes
satisfactions
laurence eux et moi avons moins beaucoup
travaillé pendant sept cette campagne et
les électeurs nous l'ont bien rendu et
je pense que le score est sans appel
donc c'est une belle victoire pour le
canton pour nos communes pour la
communauté d'agglo de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi été bien
sûr pour le département des événements
pour la première fois depuis 1994 le
canton de montigny le bretonneux vient
de passer à droite un canton qui a
désormais la même couleur politique que
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin et le département des yvelines
c'est très important parce qu'on va
justement renforcer la synergie entre le
département et chacune des villes et là
on va optimiser vraiment ce nouveau
souffle qu'on veut donner pour pour le
département et puis pour chacune des
villes dans lesquelles justement on aura
cette possibilité de servir au mieux et
de donner le meilleur de nous mêmes élus
dès le premier tour lors du scrutin de
2008 le socialiste françois de ligne et
maire de guyancourt et conseiller
général sortant
associé à sandrine grands groupes
s'incline avec 46 52 % des suffrages
soit six points d'écart avec le binôme
de l'union de la droite après une
remarque c'est que montigny il ya 2400
électeurs de plus qui ont voté puisqu'il
ya 6000 inscrits de plus à montigny au
total il ya 1200 au d'écart c'est très
peu on est dans 53 47
donc au niveau du canton c'est
mathématique mais en tout cas pour
guyancourt je voudrais remercier toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont confirmé le
fait que
on avait une dynamique et que c'est lui
qui était forte et pour montigny on a à
peine les résultats de la tendance
nationale sur le sujet très sérieux de
l'abstention en démocratie trop
d'abstention c'est très très mauvais là
on a passé des seuils qui sont quand
même très inquiétant
je vous rappellerai que on avait 43 % de
participation c'est très faible au
premier tour on est encore moins au
deuxième tour c'est un vrai problème sur
le canton 42 82 % des électeurs se sont
déplacés dans les bureaux de vote
ces dix points de moins qu'en 2008
c'était l'autre canton avec celui de
montigny que la gauche espérait
conserver celui de trappes la faible
mobilisation des électeurs n'a pas aidé
les socialistes qui pour la première
fois à s'incline sur ce secteur au
départemental images interviews et
nicolas kirillovitch et maxime lemaire
alain ajaj maire communiste de la
verrière jeanine marie conseillère
départementale sortante ne peuvent que
constater l'ampleur de la vague bleue
leur binôme ne totalise que 46,9 % des
suffrages exprimés
insuffisant pour conserver le canton de
trappes un bastion de la gauche qui
couvre également la verrière est elle en
cours
non je suis triste pour les trappistes
triste pour les verriers roi mais triste
aussi pour la partie des élans courtois
qui ne soutenaient pas monsieur for good
ça veut dire qu'effectivement deux
villes sont éliminés de la
représentation départementale et
monsieur fourgous et mam capio
d'elancourt vont représenter nos trois
communes
l'abstention aura joué un rôle majeur
lors du second tour dans ce canton pour
jeanine marie les décisions du
gouvernement ces dernières années qui
ont entraîné une déception d'une partie
de la population explique un manque de
motivation pour se rendre aux yeux
je pense que les gens justement parce
qu'ils sont deux trappes qui sont en
très grande souffrance moi je vois ça
tous les jours en tant qu'adjointe au
maire à la politique familiale je sais
quelle est leur souffrance et je
comprends je comprends leur désespoir et
peut-être même leur vote
moi je suis républicain
démocratique ans quand je vois que même
dans dans ce canton
il n'ya pas y'a pas mobilisation des
habitants de façon forte je suis je ne
suis pas satisfait ça veut dire que le
choix est fait par que 30% des personnes
qui ont voté
voilà ça ne me plaît pas jean michel
fourgous maire ump d'elancourt and capio
première adjointe à l'éducation dans
cette même ville sont donc élus avec un
peu plus de 53 % à premièrement c'est
pas un coup d'état c'est ce cd vote
c'est un vote démocratique d'abord bon
les français l'ont fallait les lillois
l'ont voulu un même moi j'ai été étonné
parce que j'ai vu les scores aux juifs
dans des bureaux ici j'ai fait 70% j'aie
jamais faits sont 10% des bureaux de
vote dans la vie m'a donc on sent bien
quand même qu'il ya un rejet comme du
socialisme abstention division de la
gauche report des voix du front national
autant de facteurs qui ont joué dans cet
entre deux tours et cette défaite de la
gauche est aussi un revers pour benoît
hamon le député socialiste conseiller
municipal à trappes qui n'a pas réussi à
contenir l'union de la droite lui qui
pourtant a largement contesté les choix
du gouvernement ces derniers mois à la
défaite de la gauche et ses verts sur le
canton de maurepas avec seulement 30 7,4
pour cent ismail havane ne retrouvera
pas son poste de conseiller
départemental florane parfait et patrick
jacques de dixmude
un résultat sans appel avec 62 64 % des
suffrages exprimés en sa faveur
le binôme union de la droite alexandra
rosetti et yves vandewalle l'a emporté
dimanche soir lors du second tour des
élections départementales une nette
victoire face aux binômes du parti
socialiste christine mercier ismaila
vannes ils ne totalisent que 37 et
virgule 36% des voix exprimées si bien
yves que moi sommes des personnes de
terrain et yves qui est quand même le
conseiller sortant a fait ses preuves je
dirais sur le comptant de chevreuse moi
j'étais maire depuis depuis un an et je
pense que les gens ont pu voir ma façon
de travailler aussi la proximité que
hiva oa également avec les habitants
dont je pense que ça c'est très
important aujourd'hui pour les gens
l'union de la droite s'impose donc très
largement sur 15 communes du canton
seuls magny les hameaux s'est mobilisée
pour le binôme ps qui remporte 51,38 %
des voix sur cette commune partout
ailleurs la droite opère un véritable
raz-de-marée même sur la commune de
maurepas historiquement socialiste avec
3200 que cette fois soit 59 18%
ce n'était jamais arrivé donc j'y vois
non seulement un formidable élan pour la
politique que je mène depuis un nom en
tant que nouveau maire de meaux repas
mais aussi un formidable élan pour
alexandra rosetti et yves vandewalle qui
viennent en tout cas sur la vie de mort
pas être élu et je pense que sur le
canton plus largement salle sera vu les
scores de maurepas qu est la ville la
plus importante du canton et donc cela
prouve que la campagne a bien fonctionné
que les électeurs ont adhéré à notre
projet le binôme socialiste n'a pas
réussi à mobiliser ses électeurs au
second tour selon elle ce mail à vannes
conseiller sortant
les électeurs ont avant tout sanctionner
la politique du gouvernement avec cette
élection
le résultat des élèves de ces élections
cantonales ne peut pas s'expliquer
uniquement par le local ou par le
redécoupage des cantons
on voit très bien qu'il s'agit d'une
vague qui arrive et une déferlante et on
le voit très bien d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui dans le canton dans le
département des yvelines vous avez zéro
conseillers départementaux de gauche ce
qui pose aussi des problèmes d'un point
de vue démocratique la droite réussit
donc le grand schelem dans les yvelines
pour le parti socialiste une réaction
s'impose c'est pas une situation
très glorieuse à l'heure actuelle pour
le parti socialiste et la gauche dans ce
département
il va falloir reconstruire c'est je
crois l'inde est un des constats qu'on
doit faire ce soir
ce soir débute la reconstruction dans
les yvelines dans nos communes du côté
de la droite on se félicite de cette
victoire pour yves vandewalle
conseillers sortants réélus
il est déjà temps de penser à l'action à
mener je crois qu'il va falloir se
préoccuper très très sérieusement
surtout du sort de la zone rurale c'est
un enjeu qui dépasse le seul cadre
yvelinois c'est valable pour toute l'île
de france
nous avons des outils les parcs naturels
régionaux par exemple nous avons des
défis tout ce qui touche aussi les
moyens de transport préoccupation pour
les gens les moyens de communication
électroniques modernes le très haut
débit internet c'est aussi un sujet pour
la zone rurale le deuxième tour des
élections départementales a moins
mobilisé les électeurs
le taux de participation est de 45,0 3%
ces trois points de moins qu'au premier
tour difficile de savoir si l'électorat
du front national a eu un impact sur le
résultat de ces élections pour les
nouveaux conseillers départementaux
cette montée en puissance du fn est un
point préoccupant dans les communes
rurales du département
lui aussi ne retournera pas à siéger
dans l'assemblée départementale
socialiste jean philippe mallet qui cède
son siège à philippe benassaya de
l'union de la droite le reportage de
yolaine thorez et elodie - ovation pour
la droite à saint cyr l'école
le duo sonia beau et philippe benassaya
vient de faire basculer ce canton détenu
par la gauche depuis 17 ans il remporte
ce second tour avec et 59 66 % des voix
c'est un beau score et puis c'est un
canton qui
qui changent de couleur donc ravis et
vraiment
prête à travailler cinq cantons qui
basculent fermement 60% des voix c'est
énorme c'est à dire que dans toutes nos
villes ont avoisiné ce score là avec des
pointes même un peu plus haut et un peu
plus bas
à vrai dire si je suis très heureux en
tant que maire de faire 60 % aussi bois
d'arcy une ville qu philippe benassaya a
fait basculer à droite l année dernière
lors des élections municipales une
dynamique on croire que lors de ce
scrutin c'est très très très belle
satisfaction d'abord parce qu'en un an
on a eu deux belles victoires on a connu
une défaite aussi dans le passé la roue
tourne
mais c'est vrai que c'est une
confirmation c'est une consolidation de
nos résultats dans nos villes c'est un
encouragement un espoir du travail qu'on
a fait depuis un an pour le binôme
socialiste qui totalise 40 points 34%
des voix
cette défaite n'est pas une grande
surprise après avoir réalisé 25% au
premier tour
fabienne gelgon bilbo et jean-philippe
eu mal est désormais ex conseiller
général salue la victoire de leurs
adversaires nous avons quand même
résisté puisque nous partons de 25% des
suffrages exprimés au premier tour pour
arriver à plus de 40%
donc on résiste on est présent nous
interroger cependant sur la démocratie
qui va maintenant régner au sein du
conseil départemental où une seule voie
sera porté celles des élus de droite qui
en plus sont déjà élus dans leur commune
europe ecologie les verts le front de
gauche n'a pas appelé à voter pour nous
mais n'a pas vais appeler à voter non
plus pour les socialistes dans d'autres
cantons nul les propriétaires de son
électorat
mais quand même je trouve qu'ils ont là
enfreint une grande règle à gauche
historique et le désistement républicain
la mobilisation était un peu plus faible
lors de ce second tour sur le canton de
saint cyr l'école 42 12% des électeurs
se sont déplacés aux urnes contre 45
points 85 % au premier tour
deux autres nouveaux élus pour un mandat
de six ans joséphine coleman berger et
bertrand coquard les représentants de
l'union de la droite sur le canton de
plaisir ils l'emportent avec plus de
2000 voix d'avancé sur leurs opposants
de gauche mikkel et demi d'euros et
william l
le canton de plaisir a basculé à gauche
depuis 2004 la liste union de la droite
menée par le duo joséphine commons
berger bertrand coq a remporté ces
élections départementales avec 58 63 %
des voix
le binôme devant sa liste socialiste
composée de frédéric evrard et de
nicholas hughes qui totalise 41 37 % des
suffrages extrêmement content
extrêmement fier je pense que c'est
aussi beaucoup de soulagement parce que
c'est pas toujours très simple parce que
ma première campagne en tant que
candidat soit toujours facile à gérer et
et c'est vrai que extrêmement content
récemment fier du résultat et du travail
en équipe qu'on a pu faire ensemble
la liste union de la droite est arrivé
en tête dans trois des quatre communes
du canton aux clayes-sous-bois la droite
a recueilli 53 50 1% des suffrages 17
points de plus qu'en 2011 le binôme a
réalisé son meilleur score à plaisir
avec 61 80 % des suffrages
un total qui ravit la maire de la
commune ça me touche beaucoup c'est vrai
que là en tant que conseiller
départemental il faut penser pour les
quatre collectivités et c'est exactement
ce que l'on va faire avec bertrand
coquard mais en même temps c'est vrai je
ne peux pas oublier que je suis maire de
plaisir et cette reconnaissance des 62 %
et est importante
ça veut dire qu'au bout d'une année eh
bien il ya encore cet accompagnement est
donc s'est dit très ému ce soir et je
les remercie vraiment en deuxième
position à l'issue du premier tour le
parti socialiste n'a pas réussi à
combler son retard de 13 points le ps
avait pourtant fusionner avec europe
ecologie les verts et le front de gauche
pour ce second tour
c'est une déception bien entendu c'est
vrai que c'est une déception parce que
c'est un canton qui détenait jusque là
depuis 2004 avec jean michel gourdon
enfin par jean michel boron
c'est une déception parce que évidemment
nous avons fait une très belle campagne
avec frédéric evrard
mais ceci dit c'est vrai que les
résultats du premier tour ne portait pas
non plus à l'optimisme béat en sachant
que les choses étaient évidemment très
très compliquée depuis ce 1er tour le
binôme joséphine comencent berger
bertrand coquard siègera pour la
première fois à versailles jeudi
prochain pour élire le président du
département
voilà pour les résultats de ces
élections est départementale et demain
mardi 18h30 une édition spéciale du 7-8
politique avec de nombreuses réactions
et des invités sur ce plateau dans le
reste de l'actualité aujourd'hui lundi à
vélizy le gardien de la résidence des
étangs entamé une grève de la faim le 19
mars suite à son licenciement pour faute
grave par la société qui l'employait la
société semiv avec sa femme ils ont été
expulsés de leur logement de fonction
durant dix jours ils sont restés dans
leurs voitures devant la résidence pour
revendiquer une annulation de cette
décision
on estime que l'on n'a absolument rien
fait que c'est un règlement de compte
personnel d'un petit groupe de personnes
de la résidence qui ont été contre nous
toute façon dès le début dès le premier
jour quasiment nous avons été licenciés
nous on estime sur de fausses
accusations
nous avons d'ailleurs 90 % des résidents
qui sont avec nous qu'ils ont signés
qu'il était complètement satisfaits de
notre travail de notre professionnalisme
ici vous avez 276 résidents et nous
allons plus de 240 personnes qui ont
signé en notre faveur nous on vivote
revendications c'est vêtue telle est
votre poche annulé annuler mon
licenciement
évidemment les copropriétaires étant
d'accord être réintégrés et reprendre
mon travail dans des conditions le plus
normale possible
26e semaine de la presse le collège
maurice ravel à montfort l'amaury qui
mobilisait enseignants et élèves de 4e
il ya quelques jours marc de chevigny
journaliste à tf1 est venu à leur
rencontre pour un échange autour de la
désinformation dans les médias les
élèves qui ont analysé des articles et
des reportages le reportage est de sonia
pro à l'envers du décor d'un journal
télévisé
voici ce que vont découvrir les élèves
du collège maurice ravel grâce à un
reportage fabriqué en interne marque de
chevigny journaliste auprès de tf1 est
venu leur présenter les différentes
facettes du métier le plus importante
c'est qu'ils retiennent c'est très
important de s'informer que la presse
quel que soit le média que ce soit eux
qui se moque ou leurs applications sur
leur smartphone mais c'est très bien
l'important c'est d'avoir c'est d'avoir
accès à l'information se renseigner et
puis qui soit capable de déterminer
quelles sources d'information le rapport
d information fiable qui soit capable de
déterminer si un contenu qui trouvent en
ligne ou ailleurs et fiable vous car ce
journaliste de tf1 est venu il y a
quelques semaines dans notre
établissement pour faire un reportage
sur le manuel numérique et les élèves
avaient vu à ce moment là la différence
entre ce qu'ils avaient vécu
et puis l'image qu'ils étaient passés
pendant le journal télévisé et c'était
très intéressant d'avoir ce retour cet
échange avec le journaliste pour pouvoir
en discuter
l'occasion pour ces élèves d'aborder
autrement ces médias qui les entoure ça
m'a apporté des explications par exemple
sur les journalistes sur leur métier sur
la désinformation
chaque pas que par exemple sur tf1 on
pouvait être au courant de tout et
n'importe quel moment
dans la minute qui suivait par exemple
entre midi et deux les collégiens
s'improvise aussi rédacteur en chef
d'information une importante et deux
autres offres secondaires d'offrir les
hiérarchiser des sélectionnés les
hiérarchiser en france près de 15000
établissements scolaires et demie médias
ont participé à cette 26e édition de la
semaine de la presse la liberté
d'expression thème décidé cette année
suite aux attentats menés contre charlie
hebdo en sport à présent c'était ce week
end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que se tenait
la coupe de france 2015 de bmx
l'événement a réuni plus de 400
participants sur deux jours de
compétition mélanie poquet elodie moines
et william l guaino était encore une
fois à l'honneur ce week-end dans les
yvelines
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a reçu plus de
400 participants pour les deux premières
manches de la coupe de france de bmx
les pilotes qu'on courait sur deux jours
dans leur catégorie pour cette épreuve
qualificative pour les championnats du
monde c'est ma première course en élite
2 donc c'est toujours un petit plaisir
et puis aujourd'hui on roule sur la
butte à 8 m donc c'est une première
aussi c'est toujours plaisir si on n'a
pas cette occasion à tous les jours avec
une nouvelle piste réaménagée pour
l'occasion plus technique le vélodrome a
séduit les pilotes qui a peu compliqué
aujourd'hui en plus c'est une piste est
très dures techniquement et puis en plus
avec le vent le vent qui se lève là ça
devient vraiment
des courses un petit peu mélangé quoi
elle elle a été rénovée et elle est
beaucoup mieux puisque avant ont été
jugées trop simple et maintenant elle et
elle est beaucoup mieux un beau
spectacle pour le public majoritairement
composé de passionnés
une occasion pour eux d'admirer les
performances des champions de cette
discipline championnat donc en fait
toute la coupe de france en jeu mieux
aujourd'hui parce que je voulais ce
matin en catégorie 19 24 et je reste
aussi tout l'après midi pour voir les
meilleures notes aux devoirs ou les
oeufs
ça fait du bien le champion national
andré sylvain rafle la première place en
élite hommes
chez les femmes c'est mariana pajon qui
se hisse à la tête du podium pour les
troisième et quatrième manches de cette
coupe
rendez-vous en charente maritime le 11
et 12 avril
et l'ensemble des résultats du week-end
ce sera dans quelques minutes sur tes
défilent pour le 7-8 sport avec michael
et demi d'euros comme chaque lundi le
journal revient demain aux mêmes
horaires nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité locale très bonne soirée
[Musique]